[Music]
hey I'm will and Noble locksmith and
you're watching my YouTube channel car
key wizard I'm an automotive locksmith
and while I definitely don't know it all
I have learned some tricks along the way
that I hope will help you while you're
out in the field
one thing you can do to help me out
though would be to subscribe to my
channel and if you like my videos leave
a comment or ask a question and I'll get
back to you as soon as I can I make a
lot of videos so if there's something
you'd like to learn more about or a
video you'd like to see on a car we're
working on just let me know in the
comments and I'll put it up as soon as I
can thanks and I hope you enjoy watching
my
[Music]
videos all right we are working on a 20
20 Honda CRV uh Pro key it's an all keys
lost she wants two keys um I'm going to
go ahead and generate the altel
universal um I have this key but I want
to just make a video on generating this
I've selected the year making model
Honda they only have uh two
possibilities or two fcci IDs for these
style proc key so you're not going to
get it wrong but just wanted to make a
video on how to make this key I love
these all Keys I've said it in another
video this key it's always going to work
so I've selected it um got to put a
battery in this key they come without it
just pop it in the uh programmer up here
hit
generate generate Universal
key and it is going to make that key um
I've already made one I'll pause this
while I get in the car and get that
started and uh we'll be back on
programming all right back in the Honda
CRV going go through manual
selection CRV smart key push to
start uh we're going to select control
unit keyless system
Honda this turn on by pressing start
button twice no it's going to tell you
to hold the ignition button about 15
seconds to turn it
on so a pretty common problem on these
vehicles Honda push to start vehicles um
once you get through I'll tell you when
we get there but if you get to
programming failed and you know you have
the right key part of the process on
these is only having one key in the car
so even though I'm making two you have
to do these one by one and you have to
keep the other one it says something
like 5 to 10
m and it ends up being right
um let's get this figure it out first
let's not do
this I know we have I got a blue light
on my
OBD let's try this again
I got the lights on I know the car is
awake um if you get to key failed one of
their keys is still in here I've had it
happen multiple
times um like I said I'll explain it
better when we get to that step but if
there is a key an existing key in here
or any other Honda procs really it's
going to fail because when it when it
opens programming to take your key in if
it sees two it's going to fail you out
of it and I don't know why but twice now
I found the existing key that the owner
of the car thought they lost in the
passenger uh seat track under up under
the seat don't ask me why but take a
shot at it if you get to that step uh
this is not going well I'm going to
switch the auto proad and be
back all right we are on a 2020 Honda
CRV um I generated to two keys with the
im608 with the altel universal Keys just
because I like those
keys and I know they are always going to
work as long as I generate the correct
key
um we're adding this is all keys lost
situation we're adding two proximity
Keys we'll try auto
search Miss does not turn on Okay now
we're going to hold
it it's going to kick the alarm back
on shut the door get rid of some of that
noise at
least
okay smart key button to
start yes the ignition is
on we're going to do all smart Keys lost
okay
um take mares out of the car more than
two meters away it is pretty serious
about that distance I was I tried this
one time by I was on top of a car hauler
by hanging off the car with my with the
key in my hand it was a good 5 ft away
and it wasn't enough so you really need
to get the other key as far away as you
can um what I do with these is put the
key that I want programmed on top of for
the dash um you can put it on the seat
there's antennas everywhere in this car
that's never failed me do center console
seat um that usually works but I am
going to put this key pretty far
away sorry about the horn nothing I can
do about
it get back in the car hit okay and it's
pretty much just going to say it took
that key
switch is on please turn that one off we
are making two keys
here all right we took that
key so we're going to switch keys
so at that step if it had said
failed that means there is another key
in this car somewhere I've had it
happened multiple times owner can't find
their key calls us for all keys lost if
it fails at that step their key is
somewhere in this car and by luck it's
worth a shot for you I've twice found it
in the seat track for the passenger seat
don't ask me why but if you get there
give it a shot it might work so we've
switched keys I took the one it took
took out put the new smart key
in vehicle is recognizing the
key switch the ignition
off switch ignition
on security light is
extinguished
yes back off
double tap back
on off
again my goodness back
on program
success so we'll cut it off try this
one oh I think I got oh yep that's good
this one is good we'll start the car it
is a hybrid so we're not going to hear
it maybe you can hear that that's on I'm
going to swap keys out try my other key
make sure they took them both I'm not I
usually do this with the Im so I'm not
really familiar with the process on the
propad but we got lock and unlock so
this is also going to start the car
proximity Keys it does the remote it
starts the car
basically car starts we are good to
go thanks for watching and good luck out
there